con tiza Blanca en este teatro de My
little escribieron la palabra niños en
ruso en el suelo en el que era el
refugio de cerca de mil civiles ahora el
edificio está destruido tras ser
bombardeado por las fuerzas rusas Aún se
desconocen número de víctimas según el
teniente de alcalde de la ciudad el
ministro de exteriores ucraniano dijo
que Rusia sabía que su objetivo era un
refugio de civiles
otro horrendo crimen de guerra en
mariopol ataque masivo ruso contra el
teatro dramático donde se escondían
cientos de civiles inocentes el edificio
está ahora totalmente arruinado
imposible que los rusos no supieran que
se trataba de Un refugio para civiles
salven a mariupol detengan a los
criminales de guerra rusos Este es el
último de una serie de ataques rusos
contra edificios civiles y contra
civiles directamente en Cherry hiv las
tropas abatieron a 10 residentes que
hacían fila para comprar pan algo
confirmado por el fiscal general de
Ucrania la Embajada de Estados Unidos en
kiev lo señaló como un ataque horrible
hoy las fuerzas rusas dispararon y
mataron a 10 personas que sean fila para
comprar el pan en Cherry este tipo de
ataques horribles deben parar estamos
considerando todas las opciones
disponibles para asegurar la
responsabilidad de cualquier criminal en
Ucrania en la capital las operaciones de
rescate se pusieron en marcha tras el
ataque ruso a 12 edificios uno de ellos
de 12 pisos 37 personas fueron evacuadas
Rusia continúa con intensos bombardeos
en todo el país incluyendo la ciudad
sureña nicolae
la única opción que tienen es borrar
esta ciudad del mapa y solo entonces
podrán pasar en teoría eso es posible
pero haremos todo lo posible para no
permitirlo
pero las tropas avanzan poco
obstaculizadas por la dificultad del
terreno local